i'm an actor i'm a factor i am a real
actor i need richard the third i was in
true west with sherman helmsley i was in
die-hard damn it
steve urkel you will suck steve uncles
if he wants you to you will suck you
understand he has our bread and butter
you mother
crazy crazy does this crazy
[Music]
you sold me out son now you gonna end up
with a bullet in your head for it
you can't play mean bubbles
i'm the mother that plays mother it's
mother god
all right everybody let's get reset we
are going again
nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah tom well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an american tough
well i'm just so glad that we got you
out of that bbc commitment so you can
play with us
cheers mate cheers antoine listen i'm
just not buying that you're someone that
was born and raised in the streets of
brooklyn
that's weird cause i actually was born
and raised on the streets of brooklyn
i was in the gang and everything most of
this stuff actually happened to me
wow okay well that's that's that's great
for us
cause i want you to use it okay it's
good first take let's just uh let's get
going
let's go let's get going thank you jim
scene five take two
and action you sold me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for me
you can't play me [ __ ]
i'm the mother that plays mother that's
mother
cut cut okay uh
nigel that was great oh brilliant just
the way you move
especially when you talk i just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes
cheers cheers he's fabulous antoine your
performance
um it's just not quite there
yet okay i i really need to see you make
more of a transformation
okay like like nigel here
that dude's british yeah antoine if i
might jump in with a bit of advice
i don't think i need it no no no no look
hear him out
maybe you might want to try thinking of
something in the material that's similar
to something that's happened in your
real life
um for me for instance i i like to think
of when
my mom wanted me to attend prep school
in leeds to become a barrister but i
wanted to study the theater
at oxford thank god and so that was a
conundrum really for me
i'm gonna stop you right right there
cause it's just confusing me
right like i don't need that cause i am
from the streets
i was in a gang they
told me to kill my cousin
might be a bit spot-on no yeah that's a
bit spot-on
do you have any stories that involve
your mom
what's a mama oh yeah
scene five take three okay
antoine remember you're a gangster
okay betrayal the streets
okay nigel you're perfect antoine
transform
and action you sold me out son
now you're gonna get a bullet up in your
head for it
you can't play me [ __ ]
he's boring to watch
cut that does not sound good
aunt i do not feel like you have found
the emotional core of this character man
this nobody is more real than me okay
i come from the streets and nobody's
going to tell me what the streets is
like
nobody you understand
that's a great speech i just wish that i
believed it you want to give it a shot
sure i'll have to go man this i'm as
real as it gets
yes this street is for real i'm up in
there man you are
from the from the from the earth from
these streets from the start
something to that defense no but i'm so
with you i'm with you when you say that
even when you're saying the wrong words
i just wish you could do that
[Music]
oh goodness
okay that hurts but i don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional place
for the character all right here give it
a shot give me
watch watch oh that's
that's great i feel that in here
and in here very gracious in my heart
try that again
i just i don't i don't believe you
call my agent
jaden pickett smith my man what up clyde
hey look man i'm gonna be real with you
okay this alien boy script
i'm not feeling it i mean it's hard
being will smith's son
i just want to make sure my next project
reflects that i'm a down-to-earth normal
kid
am i making any sense yeah yeah i'm
reading you loud clear i've got a script
right here
very real called street ball talk to me
okay so you play tony
he's a kid from the streets lives in the
hood in a house with his mom stop
house oh it's like a tiny mansion
got it go on so his mom and he uh they
live in this house and she works at a
supermarket
uh a supermarket's like a mansion uh but
it's full of food and anyone can go
there
so like where the butlers go yeah
basically so so he uh
and wait you said his mom was doing
something at the supermarket
working so working is kind of like
acting on a set every day in a film that
no one's ever gonna see
and it lasts for the rest of your life
oh like a maid
yeah yeah she's like the maid of the
supermarket awesome continue
so anyway tony doesn't make the
basketball team right so he decides to
start playing pickup games of street
ball outside
so he plays basketball in his plane
no on the ground in his limo
no uh outside is that stuff that goes by
when you're inside the limo
oh snap he plays basketball outside the
limo door
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so then he gets
really good at basketball
and then blah blah blah fast forward at
the heart of the story tony has to
choose between
his mom
yeah choose is when you have to make a
decision between two things you want but
you can
have only one but there's two
yeah but but i mean he he can't have
both
what'd i say about science fiction clyde
it's a no
okay we'll pass
dad bless you thanks okay guys
gremlins too i'm telling you this movie
should write itself the first one was a
classic this should be pretty
straightforward basically
all we're doing is maintaining the
integrity of the original picture
we want to do all the stuff with the
water and the
uh can we help you i'm sorry
let me introduce myself hi y'all
my name is star magic jackson jr i'm the
hollywood
sql doctor so studio just brings me in
to oversee
things when they about to drop a deuce
so that's why i'm here but don't mind me
i'm just gonna be over here y'all do
your thing it's your movie
okay uh let's brainstorm
adam uh if it's gonna take place in an
office building i was thinking what if
uh gizmo gets wet from a water cooler
this time okay hold on a second
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to step in here
just one second sweetheart so what's
wrong with y'all
y'all looking like a bunch of sad sacks
this
is g2 people we write in gremlins too it
should be a party
with pizza and anchovies pineapple just
come on lift up the spirits look okay
i'm gonna put a little bit of spice
into the mixture here what if we did
this
everybody here gets to design their own
gremlin
um i i don't see that the uh the gremlin
design is broken
it's called brainstorming i'm brain
drizzling sweet pea okay
shut your mouth for a second look here's
the thing
none of this is finals so you mean like
what if there was like a brainy grandma
a brainy gremlin you talking about a
gremlin with glasses who could talk and
sing new york new york
that's brilliant it's in the movie done
whoa whoa you said that nothing was
final that was before i heard the words
brainy and gremlin in the same sentence
together it's done i love it it's in the
movie next
what about a uh spider gremlin you mean
a gremlin with eight legs and the four
racks just catching pretty ladies in a
web in an office building oh my god it's
in the movie i love it
next what about a bat grandma you mean a
gremlin with leathery wings just flying
around flip-flopping bust through a wall
make a perfect bat symbol in the wall
get outside getting some wet concrete
jump up on a building that just dry in
place like a gargoyle gremlin we are
cooking with gas now i love it it's in
the movie next
could there be a female gremlin lipstick
boobies [ __ ] you have me and little
gremlin but jj i love it so much that
it's not only in the movie but it's
definitely
in the movie there's no backseats on
that one no penny taxis yes
yes yes in the movie done that's why we
need a woman in the writers room next
i don't know a googly-eyed gremlin
but you do know because you talking
about a gremlin whose sole
purpose in this film is just that he
looks stupid
yes it can be in the movie and it is in
the movie done
next what about you silver fox oh
electricity gremlin
you just said noun and gremlin like you
playing mad libs you're just like a
child you have the brain of a child
you do not have a high iq but you have
hats and he came
up with a gremlin that's just made out
of bolts that are zigzagging all over
the room and is done completely in
animation
you a crazy person and your ideas in the
movie done
next uh can we put the hulkster in it
what
[Music]
you talking about putting hulk hogan
professional wrestler turned actor
turned cultural icon in the movie
where he break the fourth wall of the
movie he's in by talking to the audience
you sir a raging psychopath
don't let this town take that away from
you
that's it i don't even care anymore we
got the hulkster in this [ __ ] so it's
done
i don't have any more time so let me
just recap right now it's brainy
gremlins fighter gremlin back gremlin
lady gremlin googly eyed gremlin
electricity gremlin hulk hogan's gonna
be in the picture i'm gonna throw in a
gremlin myself
vegetable gremlin just write it up i'm
having so much fun
thank you it's all gonna be in the
actual film now i gotta go put some
cowboys and back to the future three
sayonara y'all
no okay you guys know that none of that
is gonna be in the actual movie
[Music]
[Applause]
let me throw this
what's the matter rich in the next
episode steve urkel turns
carl into a giant sandwich and
accidentally eats him
oh wait that's hilarious but it's
hilarious come on i'm an actor gene
this was supposed to be about me and my
family no but you know after that after
that first
death spot with steve urkel i mean
america fell in love with him man we had
to make him a regular and
you know hey listen he's the star of the
show now sweetheart we gotta play ball
bubba
don't you dare bubble up me gene now
last week
steve used his transformation machine to
turn carl into a car
and drive him around the monaco grand
prix come on
how many times are you going to use this
transformation machine this was supposed
to be a blue collar cosby show
now you turn it into goddamn quantum
leap who writes
i i couldn't tell you even if i wanted
to okay i mean we got like 21 writers up
there okay you know what i'm saying
reginald but you and i both know that
they don't decide what happens in the
show okay we both know who decides what
happens in the show
two weeks ago steve urkel used his
invisibility ray on carl
and i wasn't even in the goddamn episode
it was just my voice yes i know i know
rachel i'm sorry i
apologize will never happen again then
steve used his voice changing ray to
turn carl into a high-pitched
nerdy voice who do you think provided
the voice for that don't get too
feisty on me now reg let's not go down
that path okay oh oh we're going down
that path
gene in a couple of weeks harriet eddie
laura
grandma aunt rachel little richie and
the other little kid
are gonna get teleported to another
dimension and then steve injects carl
with his own dna so carl turns into
another steve urkel
that's two steve urkels and no family on
a show called family matters how the
[ __ ] does that work listen listen wretch
i don't want to tell you urkel mania is
unstoppable okay he's a phenomenon
there's nothing we can do about okay
it's up to
him no no no no no i'm an actor i'm a
factor i'm a real
actor i need richard the third i was in
true west with sherman helmsley i was in
die-hard damn it
steve urkel you will suck steve uncles
if he wants you to you will suck do you
understand he has our bread and butter
you mother
i am high on cocaine i've done more
cocaine than you weigh
mother i'm gonna tell you what you are
wrestling phil johnson
you're a pawn in that nerd's game
you are a pawn do you think i have any
power over what that monster does
any power at all
i am the senior vice president of
development
for the american bro
gene gene
gene what's become of eugene
[Music]
i am nothing
do you know i don't know what you mean
by that to you but you're scaring me no
no don't
don't do anything crazy gene everyone
does too much coke sometimes but
just what are you gonna do with the gun
gene what are you gonna do no
no no no no no we can talk this through
uh okay the king is dead
long live the king
did i do that
[Music]
jaleel jaleel there is no jalil
only steve it's always been steve
give me kylie mother
forgetting something carl don't you come
near me
stay away from me here could have all
been so simple
carl just say your lines
and take the money your monster
what are you doing i i i i can't control
am i doing this no no
no no no no no no see i'll do anything
you will do what i want on family
matters
yes oh of course steve
[Music]
see you on set carl
get out of my house steve
hello everyone i'm joseph carmichael
otis is
was my father but we are not here today
to mourn his death
but to celebrate his life we knew otis
as a teacher
a community leader a role model a
husband
and a father now i thought it would be
nice to share something about him you
all may not have known
when my father was younger he was an
actor in hollywood
going through my dad's things i found
this reel
of his work as an actor i haven't seen
it yet
but i thought it would be fun to watch
here
with all of you today
where are my pies ripples
where are the pies i put on my
windowsill
why i don't know miss nicaragua
why would anyone want to steal one of
your delicious blueberry pie
[Music]
hey see to it you shine those shoes up
nice boy
yes sir you best be believing i will
i'll shine your shoes blacker than my
mama's booty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
in 1964 my father marched with
martin luther king jr and herrera
belafonte
along with other renowned civil rights
leaders